[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAAD ALI: Hello, everyone.
We're here at KubeCon
Barcelona with Bryan Liles.
Brian is senior staff
engineer at VMware
and also the
co-chair of KubeCon.
Bryan, can you talk
to us a little bit
about what that role is
and what it involves?
BRYAN LILES: So
the co-chairs, we
plan this whole entire
conference sans the vendor
stuff.
So all the sessions,
all the keynotes,
we coordinate the people
who do the reviews,
we make the final reviews,
we create the schedules,
we get everybody in line.
As you know, we sit down
with our keynote speakers,
and we help them
make better talks.
Everything you see at
the conference that
makes you happy, we had a
hand in it, most likely.
SAAD ALI: That's awesome.
So how did you get
involved with this,
and why did you think
that this was something
that you really wanted to do?
BRYAN LILES: CNCF
contacted me last year.
I had already done work
with Linux Foundation,
helping planning the
OS summit for a while.
And I think that they saw
that I was good on stage
and I was able to do
planning for conferences.
It was actually a good
fit for a position
that opened up late last year.
SAAD ALI: In terms of how you've
seen KubeCon evolve over time
and what's different at this
KubeCon, what do you see?
BRYAN LILES: So one thing
we highlight this morning,
there is 7,700 people here.
This is literally the biggest
open-source conference
in Europe.
And when we do our next
one in the United States,
it will be the biggest
open-source conference
in the world.
That comes very
far from whenever
we met in San Francisco and
then when we did Berlin.
SAAD ALI: How do you
make sure that this is
happening in a sustainable way?
BRYAN LILES: It's all
about the open source,
not about your company.
You work at Google.
I work at VMware.
But you notice that we're
not selling anything.
We're basically talking
about the benefits
of the open-source community.
Really, what this
conference is about
is showing what
everyone has to offer,
offering open-source
content to our people,
and making sure that it's just
not a sell fest because this
is not a vendor event.
SAAD ALI: So it
sounds like the future
is moving beyond
Kubernetes and figuring out
what we can do with
the building blocks
that Kubernetes has offered.
BRYAN LILES: Yeah.
I think that's actually it.
Kubernetes was never supposed
to be end all be all.
It's-- basically, it's
compute, network, and storage.
Everything else needs
to be provided outside.
And I'll speak for
VMware in a little bit
because we've been doing this
literally for 20 years now,
basically the software
defined data center.
What we're seeing
is now, growing
in this cloud-native way, it
just opens up so much space.
And then looking
at what Google did,
Google starts in the
ad space, and then got
really good at compute.
But now you're
seeing that we all
need to move in a
different direction
because, unfortunately, none of
us have cracked this nut yet.
And that's great.
That's amazing.
That means we're making progress
and we haven't stagnated yet.
SAAD ALI: So one of
the really cool things
I've seen at the conference
was the mental health session.
I think it was borne
out of the realization
that folks are starting to
burn out in the community.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
BRYAN LILES: When we did
Seattle back in December,
we always have a
retrospective session.
It's really the last
session, the last day,
anyone who wants to come.
There's a lot of sentiment in
that room where this is hard,
and you want to go
to all the talks,
and you want us to
meet all the people.
And we're humans, and
we can't handle that.
So we always were
paying attention to it.
But Cheryl Hung, who
works with the CNCF,
she actually went
the extra step.
And they coordinated with
people, that they can actually
have a booth downstairs
in the sponsor showcase
that you could talk to
if you get burnt out.
But I also want to
encourage anyone--
if you think about this,
a conference is just that.
It's a conference.
And there's going
to be-- there's
going to be hallway
track, there's keynotes,
there's tutorials, and then
there's general sessions.
The best thing about
a conference like this
is generally almost
everything is recorded.
SAAD ALI: So, last question--
what are you looking forward to
at KubeCon?
BRYAN LILES: So this year, what
I'm looking forward to is--
there's a lot of
software being announced
and people talking about
these projects that
go above and beyond.
So what I'm looking for is
something that I didn't expect.
And it's kind of weird to
say, but we go to these talks.
And you're like,
oh someone's going
to talk about service mesh.
Oh, I know you're
going to talk about--
I want someone to go
further than that,
and maybe take service
mesh, or anything else
even further than it is, or even
storage further than it is now.
That's what I'm looking for.
I'm looking for the
things that will probably
hit main line in the next year.
But I want to hear about it now
so I can start following along.
SAAD ALI: Awesome.
Thank you very
much, Bryan Liles.
BRYAN LILES: All right.
Thank you, Saad.
[MUSIC PLAYING]